The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So we have been
talking a lot about, sort of,
the theory of things,
but I know you guys
want to get into the practice.
At the end of
class, we have a lot
of plastic elements
in the back that Ceri
will help you guys check out.
Some cameras, mics,
headphones, tripods.
If you guys want to
just use your iPhones
for tonight's assignment,
that's totally fine as well.
Chris brought up a lot of really
good points of just framing,
practicalities of filming.
I do want you to consider,
though, that web video breaks
a lot of these rules as well.
So you'll notice that Sideshow
doesn't do the rule of thirds
framing at all.
Hankering just--
AUDIENCE: All rules
are made to be broken.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yes, yes.
But he does that
very intentionally.
A lot of it is because--
the way his videos go,
he'll look to the side and
a little image will pop up.
So I think part of what he
does that is to leave room
for some of those visuals.
And Vsauce does it because
he's just super up-close.
It's a little weird
to do a rule of thirds
when you're so up-close because
you don't have a background
to get rid of so much.
So don't feel like you
have to adhere to a rule
just because we said,
you have to do this,
you have to do this.
Thoughtfulness is
one of the values,
so as long as you justify
it in your reflection
or in your assignments
somehow, it's totally fine.
So for today's assignment, in
addition to the two readings
that are online-- and don't
worry, they're pretty short
and they're fun-- we're
going to have you guys make
a video on, basically, a circus
sideshow pitch about a video
that you're eventually going
to make for your final project.
And it's OK if this
ends up changing,
it's just an exercise to
get you guys started, to get
you familiar with the camera.
Don't worry about doing crazy
camera moves or anything.
If all you want to do tonight
is to set up your tripod
and mic up, and deliver your
pitch, that's totally fine.
We just want you
guys to get familiar
with all the equipment.
But, basically, it is going
to be selling an idea or topic
about science, technology,
engineering, or math that
should convince someone to want
to watch your eventual video.
And again, it's OK if
you change the idea.
I do want you guys to brainstorm
three ideas in addition
to the pitch video
that you make.
You don't have to post them
online or write them down.
Just have them in your
head for class tomorrow
because we're going to have some
very special guests speakers
first thing tomorrow, who will
help you with these pitches.
So to give you an idea
of the type of thing
that we're looking for.
Again, don't necessarily
copy this video exactly.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What is the most
astounding fact
that you can share with
us about the universe?
-The most astounding fact--
-The most astounding fact.
- --is the knowledge that
the atoms that comprise life
on earth.
The atoms that make
up the human body
are traceable to
the crucibles that
cooked light elements into
heavy elements in their core,
under extreme temperatures
and pressures.
These stars, the high
mass ones among them,
went unstable in
their later years.
They collapsed
and then exploded,
scattering their enriched
guts across the galaxy.
Guts made of carbon,
nitrogen, oxygen,
and all the fundamental
ingredients of life itself.
These ingredients become part
of gas clouds that condense.
Collapse.
Form the next generation
of solar systems,
stars with orbiting planets.
And those planets now have the
ingredients for life itself.
So when I look up at
the night sky-- and I
know that yes, we are
part of this universe.
We are in this
universe, but perhaps
more important than
both of those facts,
is that the universe is in us.
When I reflect on
that fact, I look up--
many people feel small,
because they're small
and the universe is
big-- but I feel big.
Because my atoms came
from those stars.
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: So
obviously you don't
have to do a super dramatic
thing like Neil deGrasse
Tyson did.
Again, don't feel like you
have to go home and contemplate
on life's mysteries, and
how evolution is just
this beautiful thing
that happens on earth,
and it's an amazing
thing or whatever.
But the reason why
I wanted to show you
that video is because the actual
plastic elements of making that
were pretty straightforward.
Pretty simple, just two
cameras on a tripod.
Nothing too crazy.
But he still, hopefully,
manages to engage you somewhat.
I mean, I personally
wanted to keep watching,
keep learning about it.
That's partially because
of his persona, which
some people find off-putting.
So again, it's a
matter of taste.
What he does here
is just, sort of,
rattle off this theme
of-- I think the thesis
of this whole conversation
that they have is
that you take this
misconception that we all
think that we're
part of the universe,
but really the universe, and
all the things that make it up,
are inside of us.
He has this sort
of fact, or nugget,
that he builds upon to
create this bigger narrative.
All right, so for Science
Out Loud, George and I
just did an episode on snot.
And the way we
started it way was--
one of my former professors
here, Katharina Ribbeck.
Her lab studies mucus, and
I was reading about her
in Popular Science,
because she just
got this big feature in it.
And one of the facts
they talked about
was that your body produces
over a gallon of mucus a day,
which I thought was, like--
how does that happen?
That's disgusting.
We think of snot as the stuff
that oozes out of us when we're
sick, and the stuff that
we blow out into tissues
and throw away.
But actually it's so
important that our body makes
over a gallon of it a day.
And that it does more than
just come out of our nose
when we're sick or
when we're crying.
That it's doing things,
like providing moisture
for our bodies, which doesn't
sound like a big deal, right?
Until you think about
your body without mucus.
That your eyes would dry
out, and you wouldn't
be able to swallow because your
esophagus would get ripped up
every time you tried
to eat something.
And then you think of mucus of
being more than just this sort
of bodily waste that
comes out of you,
but really this amazing
thing that takes care of you
in a way that's so
important that you
make over gallon of it a day.
And that sort of
became the pitch
the circus sideshow, step
right up type of thing that
informed the rest of our video.
And so that's the
kind of thing I
want you guys to be
thinking about tonight,
and want you guys to record.
Now we very well could have had
you guys just write a pitch,
but I think it would be
more fun to make a video.
I mean, I think it's
good for you guys
to get used to using the cameras
and the plastic elements.
So again don't worry
about-- are my camera
movements good enough?
You don't even have to move the
camera if you don't want to.
Feel free to play around
with it if you want.
But really focus on clarity
for this assignment.
So set up the camera
in such a way,
and set up the
lighting in such a way
that you're very
clearly visible.
We are going to give you
these little lavalier mics,
so make sure that your
audio's very clear.
Those are going to be the
priorities for this assignment.
And then make your
pitch very engaging,
and think of three backup
ideas just in case.
Does that sound good?
I had one more example, too.
We can show it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Hello, this is Hank Green,
and welcome to SciShow.
You might have noticed I talk a
lot about how great plants are.
And why shouldn't I?
They're autotrophs.
They can harness the raw,
untamed power of the sun
and use it to make
food for themselves.
Pretty impressive.
So why can't animals do it?
Well oddly enough,
some of them do.
And in just the past
few years, researchers
have been discovering
animals that
seem to be able to harvest
sunlight for energy.
Take for instance, the eastern
emerald elysia, a sea slug that
looks like a big floating leaf.
It lives along the East
Coast of the United States,
where it just hangs out eating
a specific kind of yellow-green
al--
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: So I
just wanted to show
you that as an example
of a style and delivery.
It's very different from
the Neil deGrasse Tyson,
but again, same concept.
So don't feel like you have
to be Neil deGrasse Tyson.
Don't feel like you have to be
Hank Green and talk like this,
and jump back and forth between,
like, closeup and wide screen.
But hopefully that
gives you an idea
of what you guys
need to make tonight.
If you guys have any questions,
I'll stick around after class.
You can always email me too.
So for tonight,
stem pitch video.
Ceri's going to
come and talk now
about what that process
exactly looks like.
But basically, always
look at the online version
of the syllabus, because I might
tweak some things day to day,
but the stuff for day one is
totally up-to-date right now.
You'll post yours stem pitch
to Tumblr with the hashtag
"dayonepitch" and a hashtag
of your Kerberos ID,
so that's-- all
the SUTD students,
you guys have an MIT ID, right?
OK, so it's just your username.
And then you'll
post a daily blog,
and that's going to
happen every day.
Just reflections of
what happened in class.
If you want to take
pictures during class,
if you want to record video
tomorrow, feel free to.
Tomorrow will be a great day
to record video, just saying.
And then there are
two readings that I'd
like you guys to annotate on
Annotation Studio, which Ceri's
going to show you
right now, as well.
And then just bring three other
pitch ideas to class tomorrow.
Did everyone get the email
about class timing shifted up
tomorrow?
So if you guys want
to show up at 12:10,
that would be good,
because our guest
lecturers are coming at 12:15.
And we'll end class
at 3:15 tomorrow.
CERI RILEY: This is
Annotation Studio.
It's on annotationstudio.org
and it's
where you're going to be doing
your reading assignments.
So what you need to do is
just go to the website.
Click sign up for sign in.
And it's a really easy
registration form.
First name, last name,
email, I use my MIT email.
Affiliation, just put MIT.
And a password.
And the most important
thing, so you
can get the assignments
in the first place,
is to type in the class.
So you just need to
do 20219, press Enter,
and it'll be blue, to like,
confirm that you're in it.
Read and accept the terms
of service, check that box,
and register.
And so I'll show you
what it looks like.
So this is what you'll
see when you sign in.
You won't have any
created documents,
but you'll have
assigned documents.
The two that we want
you to read and annotate
are the first two-- "You Can't
Make It on YouTube Anymore,"
and "This Will
Revolutionize Education."
You'll click on it,
and it'll bring you
to the document itself.
So for example, this
is the first one.
And you'll be able to read
along and highlight it, and add
in your thoughts
as you go along.
So for example,
you're reading it.
You're reading about
Hank Green, and how he
was invited to New TeeVee Live.
I was starting my own
online media conference,
and maybe you're thinking,
well what is that?
So you can say, does anyone--
[TYPING]
And then add some tags.
I don't know what tags really
do, but then everyone can see
that annotation and who did it.
And I'm not sure, because
we haven't played around
with this software too
much, but you probably
will be able to comment on
each other's annotations.
So if for some reason someone
poses a question like this,
and someone knows the
answer, it's Vid Con.
Then they can respond.
You can add pictures,
you can add links.
And it's just really
handy because then you
can see people's idea flows as
they go through the document.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Just
so you guys know,
we're grading the annotation
just on a three point scale.
If you put effort into
it, you put marginal,
if you did it at all.
Don't feel like that you have to
spend hours and hours on this.
These readings are pretty fun, I
mean, one was posted on Medium.
It's not a super dry
academic platform.
And the other one's
a YouTube video.
So just respond honestly.
Don't feel like we're expecting
huge analyses of these,
but we do want to see you
guys creating it and taking
[INAUDIBLE].
CERI RILEY: OK, the other thing
I was going to show you guys.
How many of you have used
Tumblr before as a platform?
OK, so a couple.
So that's going to be our main
blog, I guess, for this class.
I've sent you guys all an email
invitation to join the website
and be able to use it.
This is what the
main website looks
like, you should have already
looked at it earlier today.
The main things
are that there are
links on this top bar to the
stellar, which we probably
won't use, Annotation
Studio, and an ask box.
And so I'll be on the Tumblr
monitoring it all the time.
So you can ask questions there.
There's lists of
all our Kerberoses,
so we'll organize our
posts with your MIT ID.
Then it's also
organized so you can
look at specific assignments,
like day one, daily blogs,
and things like that, which are
all sorted and dependent on you
guys tagging your
posts correctly.
And then there's also
reference material.
This bottom tab on
the left side bar
is probably most
useful for you guys.
I can't scroll down right
now because there aren't
enough posts, but it
has things like a list
of all the assignments
that Elizabeth will post.
Answered questions, and a
how to use Tumblr and upload
videos on YouTube, which I'll
go through, hopefully, really
quickly, so you guys don't
have to stay too long.
For those of you who haven't
used Tumblr, when you login,
when you accept the
invitation to join the blog,
it'll look like this.
This is your dashboard.
I have multiple accounts, and so
if you have multiple accounts,
you have to go up here,
and choose MIT 219.
And this is going to be
exactly what your dashboard is
going to look like.
And so, from here, you can
make different types of posts.
We're probably going to use two
most often, text and a video.
And so for a text post,
you just click Text post.
You can give it a title.
Put something in the body.
And we request that you tag
things with specific names
depending on the assignments.
So Elizabeth gave
examples of what
we want you to do for your
daily blogs, which is "day one",
or whatever data is
and your MIT Kerberos.
And so for example, if this
was my daily blog for today,
I would type in "day
one", enter, and then
my Kerberos, which is ceriley.
And it'll be different
for your video
that you end up
uploading to the site.
And you can include
images in this.
You can include other things,
like links if need be,
if you find that
necessary to your blog.
And click Post.
And then you should be
able to see it right here
on your dashboard, and
also on the website
if you go click there.
OK so if you're making a
video post-- how many of you
have-- have any of you uploaded
a video to YouTube before?
OK, this is more familiar.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Is there
a way to just upload
directly your files
to Tumblr, right?
CERI RILEY: There
is, but there's
a five minute limit per day.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So for tonight's
assignment, if you just
want to upload your raw
video file to Tumblr,
that's totally fine.
But eventually, for
some of the drafts,
you may need to
upload it to YouTube.
CERI RILEY: So I'm just going to
go through this really briefly.
YouTube.com.
If you have a Gmail account,
you have a YouTube account
automatically.
They're linked because
Google owns everything.
Just click Upload in the
upper right hand corner.
Select files to upload.
I have an example video
that I shot this morning.
OK, so here you have
basic information.
You can choose a title.
A description.
And this is-- you can tag
it with anything you want.
This is the key part,
I think, to YouTube,
is where-- how you
want to upload it.
So public means anyone can
search it through the search
bar, through Google searches.
It'll be available
to the public.
Private means you have to
enter certain email addresses,
and those are the
people who can access
it using their Gmail accounts.
I like doing unlisted
personally because then,
if you have the link to the
video, you can access it.
But if you don't have the link
to the video, you can't see it.
It keeps, like, my draft
videos like this one, no one
will want to watch it.
Eight seconds of me
talking to a phone camera.
Private enough from, like,
the rest of the world.
But you can still post the
link places, like the Tumblr,
and have it be accessible.
And so I like unlisted,
but you can do whatever
you want with your videos.
So you saw that the video
uploaded, and then it
takes a little time to process.
And that's just
YouTube doing things
so that it can be played.
That's my video.
Now it's available, the
processing is really quick
because it was eight seconds.
And to upload on Tumblr, just
copy the URL or the embed code.
Make a video post.
Paste it in here.
There's no thumbnail yet
because I haven't chosen one.
YouTube sets one automatically
after a couple minutes.
I can tag it with day one, and
my username, and set a caption.
And post it.
And it will appear on my
dashboard, and on the website.
So this is just like
the general process.
Under the References
tab on the Tumblr,
there's more detailed if you
forget any of these steps.
Or are having any
trouble, or feel free
to email me at any time and
I could help troubleshoot
any steps of this process.
If you prefer
Vimeo, you can also
upload it there and
just paste in the URL.
If you already
have Vimeo account,
or something like that.
So I know we held you guys
to the last possible minute,
so we'll let you
go ahead and go.
ELIZABETH CHOE: If you
need any equipment tonight,
Ceri and I will stick around and
check out stuff to you that you
can keep for the month.
If you want to just use
your iPhone tonight,
that's also fine.
Just make sure you're
lit well enough,
and that we can hear you
well enough for tomorrow.
And if you have any questions,
we'll stick around after class.
So see you tomorrow at 12:10.